the 2020 presidential race could see a
big shake-up very soon former New York
City Mayor Michael Bloomberg is thinking
of adding his name to the list of
Democratic candidates in response
senator Elizabeth Warren welcomed the 77
year old media mogul to the race and
suggested he check out her ideas for
helping everyday Americans senator
Bernie Sanders tweeted that billionaires
like Bloomberg should be quote scared ed
O'Keefe is covering campaign 2020 and
good morning as I recall this is not the
first time Bloomberg has considered
running for president oh that's right
Tony if we had a dollar for every other
time we heard that he might do this well
we still wouldn't be as wealthy as him
but what makes this significant is that
he's actually doing some of the
paperwork now to get into the race he
sent aids to Alabama which has the
earliest filing deadline for the
presidential elections it's today all of
this is a sign he's opening the door
wider than he ever has before this
country is in real trouble we need
somebody to pull people together just
last week former Mayor Michael Bloomberg
said he had doubts about the current
Democratic presidential contenders I had
my reservations about the people running
and the way they're campaigning and the
the promises they're making that they
can't fulfill now after spending
millions to help Democrats win elections
across the country he's seriously
considering a bit of his own in a
statement a spokesman says we now need
to finish the job and ensure that Trump
is defeated but Mike is increasingly
concerned that the current field of
candidates is not well positioned to do
that under Mike Bloomberg tenure in
September he told CBS this morning he
was staying out of the 20/20 race
partly because former Vice President Joe
Biden was leading a crowded field are
you sitting here going I wish I had done
it no I never think back that was not a
road for me when Joe was in the race to
get through because we would have split
the votes but recent polling shows Biden
is slipping behind liberals Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders and moderate
Indiana mayor Pete Buddha judge
Bloomberg is a former registered
Republican and independent who rejoined
the Democratic Party just last year
[Music]
he's been mentioned as a possible
presidential candidate since 2008 in
2016
he backed Hillary Clinton and attacked
then candidate Donald Trump I'm a New
Yorker and I know a con when I see one
all right let's talk details if
Bloomberg does decide to run what
challenges does he face entering this
late in the campaign and where does he
fit among the other Democrats in the
field
well sure he'd have a lot of catching up
to do to the other candidates who've
been campaigning for months but the one
thing of course he has is money and he's
expected to spend his own fortune on
building a team getting on the ballot
and advertising but a recent poll also
shows that if Bloomberg were to enter
the race only six percent of Democratic
primary voters say they definitely vote
for him he'll also have to answer for
his record as New York Mayor including
implementing the controversial policing
tactic known as stop and frisk that
disproportionately targeted minorities
it's already been the subject of
conversation on the campaign trail all
right a lot of work ahead for him thank
you very much